on the first day of Christmas my true
love gave to me a successful blackmail
ploy from the guardians of peace there
the hacker group that stole scripts
movies employee info and more from Sony
Pictures and the gifts keep coming it's
a nightmare before christmas featuring
the ghost of emails past here's what we
know so far about the Sony hack I mean
in 10 years watt-hours gonna make a
movie out of this the guardians of peace
or GOP no relation to the political
party of course threatened to attack
movie theaters that show Sony's anti Kim
jong-un comedy the interview Kim Jong
and his people believe anything he tells
them including he doesn't urinate and
defecate you tell me my men doesn't
pupil everybody pees Amber's otherwise
he explode which caused us to do to
actually cancel the film's Christmas
relief after several movie theaters
including AMC and regal entertainment
said they wouldn't show the movie it all
started with this message that the group
posted to paste bin and friend paste
because maniacal hackers use websites no
one's ever heard of soon all the world
will see what an awful movie Sony
Pictures Entertainment has made the
world will be full of fear remember the
11th of September 2001 but the
Department of Homeland Security isn't
buying it they say there's no credible
intelligence pointing to a plot against
movie theaters mmm
it's just what you want you like it the
hackers say they want to show the world
how awful the movie the interview is but
Sony itself beat them to it in an email
leaked by the GOP a UK Sony exact called
the movie desperately unfunny and
repetitive Sony's office in Taiwan wrote
we don't find it entertaining at all and
other countries agreed so guess what
guardians may be rotten tomatoes could
have done your job for you what you
hiding your butt I don't think I want to
do that you gotta put in your butt right
now it's a little big speaking of emails
the hackers stole a veritable treasure
trove of them which they've been
releasing over time besides proving that
Hollywood execs are just not very nice
who knew the emails reveal all kinds of
things that Gawker can't stop gawking at
like Angelina Jolie got called a spoiled
brat George Clooney was sad nobody liked
his movie Daniel Craig's new Bond flick
is an over-budget bus that no script
doctor can fix and other completely
unsurprising revelations then Sony
co-chairwoman Amy Pascal had to
apologize for races comment she made
about President Obama plus journalists
are now having a field day reading CEO
Michael Linton's emails take him down
you want us to assassinate the leader
North Korea yes whoa just in case these
hackers are becoming your new heroes
because didn't we all want to hurt
somebody after seeing the movie Ghost
Rider don't forget that it's Sony's
employees who've been targeted to
thousands of employees Social Security
numbers have been released along with
medical records salary info and more
Sony workers also got an email
threatening their families that included
this google translate fail it's silly to
expect in Sony Pictures to take off us
what even though it's hard to take a
group that can barely string a sentence
together seriously the Guardians have
been smart enough to blackmail a
multi-billion dollar corporation which
probably isn't a good sign for
corporations and even governments
everywhere so between these jokers and
the NSA should we all just go back to
smoke signals
Christmas is ruined